[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM POWELL: Hello, everyone.
Good morning, and
welcome to Fragments
In An Architecture
Components World.
So over time, Fragment
APIs have kind of evolved.
And as of the release of
Architecture Components,
a lot of people
have been asking us
questions like, how do all
these things fit together?
So hopefully, we'll be able to
answer some of those questions
today.
But first, just a
little bit of history.
The Fragment APIs go back to--
2010 was when they were
first initially written,
2011 when they hit a little bit
more widespread availability.
And really, it kind of
comes down to the idea
that at the very
beginning, everybody just
kind of started
with the activity
when you were writing
an Android app.
It was kind of your main
method with a lifecycle.
It's the entry point to your
application from the system.
The launcher will
launch your activity.
You get all the onCreate,
onStart, Resume, et cetera,
events that you
all know and love.
It'll create views for you.
It creates the window,
gives you a place
to inflate your view
hierarchy where you do
most of your UI work.
It binds the view content
from your app state.
Or at least this is where
people tended to do it.
Keep in mind that this was
fairly early on in Android's
public lifecycle here.
Everybody kind of had this
habit of piling everything
into one activity, because
apps were a lot more
simple than they are today.
And of course, you listen to
UI events and update that app
state from there as well.
So there are so many
incoming events,
it really kind of became
this plumbing exercise
to try to break it up yourself.
So people ended up with these
very monolithic activities.
And then something
else happened, too.
Android tablets kind
of became a thing.
So we kind of thought, how
do you make a tablet UI?
Well, you take one phone UI,
you take another phone UI,
and you smack them together,
and you have a tablet UI, right?
I mean, what could go wrong?
So we needed to answer
this question of,
how do I stick two phone
UIs together and make sure
that it still works on a phone?
And Fragments were kind of
our answer to this question.
So as an example
here, this approach
actually worked pretty
well for some applications.
Gmail is a great example.
So if you take a look
here, you have the list
of conversations to your
current conversation
that you're taking a look at.
And there's not a
whole lot of difference
here between the
phone version that you
drill into versus something
that you can show side
by side in a two pane UI.
So Fragments were
really designed
to make sure that you
could do one thing,
and that was to allow splitting
up these huge activity classes.
This was something
that, again, we
were seeing the pain that
developers were feeling
that their activity
classes were getting
really big and hard to manage.
So we wanted to
see, could we allow
for you to decouple some
of the various things
that your activity classes
are doing to sort of relieve
a little bit of that pressure?
So that means that anything
a Fragment can do--
or anything an Activity
can do, a Fragment
had to be able to do, too.
And that guided a whole
lot of the API design
from the beginning.
So that meant that you needed
to have lifecycle events.
That meant that you needed
to be able to manage a view
hierarchy.
It meant that you needed
to be able to deal
with saved instance state.
So packaging everything up
into a bundle or a parcelables
so that if your application
got killed in the background,
you could restore from
that in a clean way.
And other things as well, like
non-configuration instance
object passing.
And that's always kind of
a mouthful, but I mean,
this is kind of the way that
you can pass any old object back
and forth across a configuration
change that doesn't actually
kill your process.
Back stacks were
another really big one.
Because suddenly if you were
dealing with a single activity
where you were navigating
between fragments,
we wanted to make sure that
we preserved that same back
stack behavior
that you're used to
from just calling start
activity from screen to screen.
So along the way, we
asked the question,
can we fix some other
APIs that were really
kind of a pain in the
neck in Android to use?
On retained non-configuration
instance-- again,
kind of a mouthful.
This method kind of
had some problems,
because you only got
one object that you
could pass from activity
instance to activity instance.
We didn't give you any
easy or standardized way
to multiplex different
objects together.
So for example, if you were
composing multiple libraries,
we didn't give you
a whole lot of help.
This was all boilerplate that
you had to write yourself.
Activity show dialog, does
anybody remember this?
A few people.
OK.
IAN LAKE: Please
forget it immediately.
ADAM POWELL: Please
forget it, yeah.
So this was essentially a way
to get the activity itself
to sort of do something
that we knew was missing
and kind of a pain in the neck.
This allowed you to make the
activity on the other side
after a configuration
change, the new instance
of your activity re-show what
is semantically the same dialog.
We also had this thing, Local
Activity Manager, TabHost.
Does anybody remember this one?
Wow, that is a lot more hands
than I thought I would see.
Some of you might remember
this from, for example,
the original Dialer and Contacts
app back in kind of the Android
2.0 days.
And as you've swapped between
tabs between the normal number
pad and your contact list
or call log, et cetera,
those were actually
separate activities
showing within a smaller
window within an activity.
This idea of nesting
activities was something
that we started
offering very early.
It had a lot of
other issues, though.
Activities made a
whole lot of promises
that Local Activity
Manager had a lot
of trouble trying to uphold.
So we wanted to try and tighten
that interface a little bit
better for something
composable like Fragments that
would be able to
do the same thing
but with a little bit
more expected behavior.
IAN LAKE: Right.
So this whole idea of being
able to break up your activity
and make it into kind
of composable pieces.
We had this giant
monolith of an activity,
and there's other methods
of kind of factoring it out
into different pieces.
But for Fragments,
basically the approach
was you move that loosely
related code, those view
and all of the state around that
view into a separate fragment.
And you basically
just keep doing this
until you've kind
of segmented out
your activity into
something that
looks slightly more reasonable.
You may have a couple
of fragments in here
that kind of have their
own specific requirements
and their own specific UI.
And your activity just becomes
more of a shell for this.
But soon after we started
getting into this,
and when it came up to around
Jelly Bean, people were like,
but this isn't enough.
What if one of my Fragments
has a ViewPager in it
that also has Fragments
as each one of its pages?
So we get into
this, all right, now
let's break up the Fragments
into smaller pieces.
So of course, the
only way, well,
if Fragments aren't enough, then
you just add more Fragments.
In this case, child
Fragments became a thing.
So now each one
of these Fragments
could then be broken
up into smaller pieces.
So this allowed us to kind of,
again, kind of decouple things.
And we built a lot
of code around trying
to make this nested state
work really well to varying
levels of degree of success.
But it's gotten a
lot better over time.
So with these things in mind,
every one of those Fragments,
whether it's a small thing
just managing a view,
or if it's a retained
instance Fragment,
every single one
of these Fragments
give you lifecycle hooks.
Every single one of them
has back stack management
associated with them.
Every single one of them
has a retained object
that it can do across
configuration changes.
And all of them are
stored statefully
in your Fragment Manager.
That means that the
existence of that Fragment
is actually part of
the state of your app.
So when your app
dies and comes back,
that existence in
the Fragment Manager
is actually a really
important part that, at least
from Fragment's
perspective, that we're
going to do on your behalf.
And of course, they all
have their own ability
to have a view subtree.
So that piece of your UI
that they manage themselves.
And of course, we
also allow things
like Fragments being
inflatable and put right
into your XML files and
be able to re-use them
across multiple layouts.
And again, this is
also kind of hooking
into these same processes.
But the biggest issue we found
is that all these Fragments
do all of these things at
once, whether you want them
to or not.
And most of the time,
you're only actually using
one or two of these
things and not
the full 16 things
that fragments
do that you get as kind
of a bundle of deal.
So that means that
some of these things,
like the stateful
restoration, means
you have a lot of patterns that
look like this where you have
to make sure that the Fragment
Manager is in the right state.
So in this case, we're actually
checking, well, all right,
is there no saved
instance state, i.e.,
are we in a fresh
run of this activity?
And oh, now I need to add
my Fragment to my layout.
So if you've ever
gotten this approach
where you have one
Fragment over another one,
yeah, that's this kind
of stateful restoration
actually being something
that was a useful bit,
but at the same point, maybe not
exactly what you were expecting
or something that you even
wanted, in some cases.
But for Fragments, you
kind of got all of them
together in a package deal.
But last year, we kind of
took a more holistic approach
to how we do APIs.
And this really kind
of started with a lot
of the work we did on
architecture components.
So all of the
architecture components
have really tried to focus
in on doing one thing
well rather than being
kind of the kitchen sink
kind of approach.
So for example,
lifecycle observers--
the ability to have
lifecycle, and that on resume,
on start, as kind
of a piece that
is completely independent
from other things, something
that you can register just
if you care about lifecycle.
Similarly for a ViewModel,
we created a new primitive,
a new object,
specifically for that kind
of retained instance state or
cross configuration changes.
And of course, this
year, just yesterday,
we announced a new navigation
architecture component.
Kind of working out the much
higher level architecture
on how you build your UI and
put these things together
and really trying to tackle
just the specific problem of how
do you move from one
screen to the next screen.
So all these things were
kind of really focused
on doing one thing well.
And we're trying to bring
a lot of that to Fragments.
But that means that we kind
of have a lot of legacy
to go along with that.
ADAM POWELL: That's right.
So part of this is that
Fragments were really
designed around this idea
of very loose dependencies
and loose guarantees about
some of the interaction
between them.
So another kind of
quiz for the audience.
How many of you know the
answer to this question?
Does a child Fragment's
onCreate method run
before or after its
parent's onCreate method?
How many of you are confident
that you know the answer?
Not a whole lot.
How many of you--
IAN LAKE: No idea.
Is that an option?
ADAM POWELL: How
many of you thought
you knew the answer before
I asked the question,
and then you started
questioning yourself?
Yeah, OK.
I'll fully admit
that sometimes I
have to double
check this as well,
because the answer
really kind of depends on
whether the parent
is an activity
or if the parent's a Fragment.
What version are you running on?
Are you talking about
android.app.fragments
or the support
library Fragments?
Because the answer has
been different over time.
We've changed this around.
And if you were trying
to design a fragment that
worked across all versions
of Android that was writing
to the framework
Fragments, you had
to deal with these rules
kind of changing out
from under you a little bit.
You couldn't count on anything.
So one of the things
that we allowed for here
with lifecycle observers
is that we really
wanted to give a very strict
ordering of the callbacks.
You have a strict last
in, first out callback
ordering for all lifecycle
observers in any given
lifecycle.
This is important
because it means
that you can set up dependencies
between lifecycle observers
and use lifecycle observers
as the implementation
details of a particular activity
instance or fragment instance,
as the case may be.
You can make sure to
maintain guarantees
between certain
lifecycle events so
that any other
lifecycle observers
that other libraries
you may be using
can take advantage
of those guarantees
that you've configured.
Lifecycle observers
are created by you.
We don't try to recreate
them via reflection, which
means that you can use any
sort of creation pattern
that you may find
useful within your app.
So this seems like a
really small thing,
but it was a big
piece of feedback
that we got with Fragments.
The implication of
that, though, is
that you no longer get stateful
restoration by the system.
Now, again, in some cases,
this is exactly what you want.
You want to make sure that
you have a single control flow
path as you're configuring
your lifecycle observers.
You don't want to
be checking, hey,
is my instant state going
to bring this back for me?
I don't want to end up
with two of these things.
So on and so forth.
IAN LAKE: Right.
So one of these
really common patterns
that we saw a lot of
app developers using
is actually a headless fragment,
a fragment without a UI
that was used basically only
to receive onStart onStop
lifecycle events.
So for a lot of these
kind of approaches,
lifecycle observers
are going to give you
the same kind of API service,
but with a lot smaller kind
of API that you
don't actually need
all of the things of Fragment.
So what does this
actually look like?
You might have just a
simple lifecycle observer
that does analytics calls.
And your analytics library
might want onStart onStop
of a particular lifecycle.
So the thing here
is that this is
an independent piece from
Fragments, from activities.
That has a couple of super
important things in that one.
You can test it independently.
You don't have to spin
up the whole world just
to test this piece.
You can test it in isolation.
Also because you can
create this observer,
you can use whatever
methods you want.
If you want to use a dependency
injection kind of model
and inject in your dependencies,
that is really easy
to do in this model
rather than trying
to do it in the scope of
an activity or Fragment
or doing that kind of thing.
So this gives you a lot more
power to kind of split out
this into a composable piece.
So if you're building
a library, you
can just use this same
lifecycle observer
across all of your fragments
or all of your activities
and not have to
duplicate that data
or worry about, OK, well, what
state is my instance state in?
You can just always say, add
the observer, and we're done.
There's no more work
you need to do here.
So this offers a lot
simpler alternative
for this specific use case.
ADAM POWELL: We've got some
glowing slides to get through.
OK.
So retained instance
Fragments were really
designed to outlive an activity.
These were basically
just a setter
on a Fragment to say, hey,
retain my instant state
across configuration changes.
This was a pretty
useful thing, because it
meant that you could save
handles to expensive data
or operations.
If you start some
sort of query that
might take a little
bit to complete,
you don't want to restart
that just because somebody
rotated the screen or
something got re-sized.
It meant that you
could reconnect
to these same operations after
that configuration change.
But really, please,
don't do UI during this.
This was another one of those
kind of headache pain point
sorts of things.
Fragments do
everything all at once.
But these were two
things that just really
did not taste great together.
The reasoning for
this is, of course,
that views hold onto the
context that created them.
Well, what context do you use to
create views most of the time?
Well, it ends up
being the activity.
You don't want to hold onto a
reference to an old activity
after a configuration change
and end up using the same views.
Now, technically, it's
possible to do this right.
You can go ahead and
drop all your references
in onDestroy view,
recreate the view after you
come around the other side.
This was way too difficult
to get right all of the time,
just because references
to these views
end up leaking out and getting
everywhere no matter what
you try to do.
So this was something that
was really just kind of a foot
gun waiting to hurt people.
IAN LAKE: But of course, in the
architecture component world,
there's a different solution for
this retained instance pattern.
And that comes in the
model of ViewModels.
So this was kind of
a brand new class.
And to be honest, the class
doesn't really do a whole lot.
It's how it connects
to the overall system.
So instead of being,
again, part of the fragment
APIs, this is a more general
purpose thing, something
that you can attach to any
activity or any Fragment
or any ViewModel
store owner, if you're
building your own framework.
And the main thing
that's different here,
just kind of like the
lifecycle observers,
is that we are not the owner
of creating those objects.
So by default, we
provide a factory
that just creates a new instance
or creates a new instance
and attaches your
application context to it.
But at the same point, this is a
super powerful hook for, again,
kind of adding in those
extra dependencies.
So if you're using
dependency injection,
again, you have
kind of the hooks
you need to hook into
the view model creation
and pass those just as
a constructor parameter.
There really doesn't need to
be a more complicated structure
than that.
But you get into the same
problem of, OK, well,
how do I connect my UI?
And the other
piece of the puzzle
here is a different architecture
component called live data.
And LiveData is kind of
all about a lifecycle aware
observer.
So in this model, in this
world, your view model
is the one who's
storing the data.
And it's the LiveData that
it has that it can then
pass to the activity
or Fragment as they
get created and recreated.
And that Fragment or activity
can just observe the LiveData
that the view model owns.
So this model kind of
separates things out
where instead of it
being the view model that
needs to hold onto a
reference to views,
the activity can then
pull the information out
of the view model.
So I think for a
lot of use cases
where you're using a retained
instance state specifically
to kind of store this expensive
data and do that kind of work,
ViewModels offer a
really good alternative
to retained instance Fragments.
So what's a super
simple one look like?
Well, in this case, we're going
to use an Android ViewModel.
So here we get a reference
to your application,
your application context.
So this is really
useful if you're
doing things like a service
locator kind of pattern.
But the important thing here
is that the ViewModel stores
an instance of a LiveData.
In this case, a LiveData that
has a list of our fancily
named expensive data class.
Now, normally, you'd put this
in line, but slides are hard.
So here we're
using it, and we're
getting our data from a
room database, a simple ORM
database.
But you can really get
this data from anywhere
or set up kind of the
correct lifecycle event
here so that your
LiveData can kind of get
into the right state.
But that means that your
actual Fragments or Activities
don't need to know where
this data came from.
It's encapsulated
in the ViewModel.
And again, we're
in this same thing
where we can now test this
new model in isolation.
We don't need to
create Activities.
create Fragments
to get to this same ViewModel.
We can just use
them in isolation
and make sure that all
of the work we need here
to get our expensive
data and make sure
that it's in the right state
can all be done kind of separate
from the actual UI
pieces of the framework.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So everybody's favorite topic
when it comes to the Fragment
API is Fragment transactions.
Because this is a
statement that's said
by pretty much no one ever.
Fragment transactions are
asynchronous by default.
If you call commit on
a Fragment transaction,
then that ends up
getting posted for later,
and it'll occur kind of
on the next normal handler
pulse of your main thread.
Or if another lifecycle
event is coming up,
we'll go ahead and execute
all the pending transactions,
bring it to a consistent
state before we
move to that next state.
Now, this actually has
a few benefits to it,
believe it or not, for
as much as everybody
gets kind of
frustrated about it.
And the biggest one
is that you don't
have any re-entrant
Fragment operations.
This means that if you end
up manipulating Fragments
within, say, the onCreate
of another fragment,
then you don't start
getting into a state where
you have a half
initialized Fragment
while you're waiting to bring
another Fragment up to speed.
Now, this is a source
of countless bugs.
I think that it was even just
earlier this week, last week,
that we were helping a
developer troubleshoot
some other re-entrant behavior
bugs that were coming from view
callbacks, for example.
And this was the
sort of thing that
can be really, really subtle.
And the asynchronous
Fragment transactions
sidestep all of it.
And that was kind of convenient.
The drawbacks are, of course,
that the observed state
at any given point in
time doesn't actually
reflect any of the
queued transactions.
So this is a huge problem.
This basically means that
if one piece of your code
submits a Fragment transaction,
another piece of your code
tries to read something out of
state that that Fragment would
have set up for
you, whether that's
another view hierarchy that
would have gotten attached
to sort of a
sub-hierarchy of your UI,
or whether that's just some
data about a pending operation,
say, for one of these
retained instance Fragments.
This essentially means that
you can't trust anything
about the current
state of the app.
It means that you can
have various data races
just within the
normal main thread
handler of your application.
We've even seen people run
into the issues of sort
of the layered Fragments
on top of one another
because of this issue, because
they were checking the Fragment
Manager to see, hey, what is my
current UI pane, for example,
that's currently there.
It said, oh, look, nothing.
I don't have anything to do.
Let me go ahead and make
a new Fragment transaction
and stick something there.
But there was already
something in flight.
So this was something
that was really
kind of a pain in the neck.
And everybody loved when the
commit now API was added,
because it lets you do
something immediately as long
as you promised that you
weren't going to do anything
with your current
Fragment Manager as part
of that transaction.
IAN LAKE: But we kind
of get to this point
where, OK, now we have all
these fragment transaction
code in your app and very
subtle changes that you may not
pick up in a simple
CL all of a sudden
are changing the whole
behavior of your app.
And we really took
a look at this
and we said, well,
should you really
have to be writing all of these
Fragment transactions by hand?
For so many of the use cases,
we can do a little bit better
here.
We can do a lot better
here, especially
for the really common cases.
So we built Navigation.
A brand new
architecture component
that's really kind of focused
on that screen to screen
transitions between
Fragments or other UI pieces.
Because we really wanted to make
it work well with Fragments.
Fragments are a really
great way of getting access
to lifecycle observers
and ViewModels
and also being an
owner of a view.
And those are really
kind of the main pieces
you need when you're trying
to build a good Android app.
At the same point, we realize
there's a lot of things
that Fragments do that
we don't really want you
to have to deal with yourself.
So one of the things with
Navigation that we really
focused on was actually
being able to take ownership
of the back stack, make
sure that the Navigation
component can actually handle
that back stack for you,
whether you're using Fragments
or you're using something else.
The ownership of that back stack
kind of lays with navigation.
That gives us a lot more
flexibility and a lot more
ability to be a little bit more
prescriptive and a little bit
more opinionated on what
is a good thing to do
and what's a not so great thing
to do and kind of give you
a lot of the same power
of Fragment transactions
without actually having to
touch one with your bare hands.
Because again, we're
trying to make things
so that you have all of the
power without necessarily
the headache and
the problems that
run across some of the
things that Adam pointed out.
So we're going to be talking
in detail about Navigation
tomorrow morning at 8:30.
I know you're all early risers.
But I wanted to give you a
little bit of a preview of kind
of how simple this could be.
So we actually offer
a helper method
where if you want
to click a button
and do a full screen
transition to another Fragment,
we have a create navigate
OnClickListener that
literally just does just that.
All you need to do
is pass in the ID
of one of those
destinations that you've
set up in Navigation.
Now, this looks a
little bit magical.
So what is this actually
doing under the covers?
Well, really what it's doing is
it's using this nav controller
object.
And one of the things
that I find super useful
about Navigation
is you can actually
find that nav controller from
any view or any Fragment that's
been created by Navigation.
So here we're using
a call in extension,
which makes it a lot easier.
If you're in the Java land,
it's just a static method.
But here we can find
from any view we can just
say find nav controller and
get an instance of our nav
controller.
And then just call Navigate.
And this Navigate call knows
how to do Fragment transactions.
So our nav controller,
in this case,
is set up with a
Fragment navigator.
Our own class that knows all
about the correct behavior
of doing Fragment
transactions and how
to do all of that work for
you so that from your code's
perspective, you can
just call Navigate,
and we'll do the
right thing for you.
So obviously, there's
a lot more here.
Like, if you want
to pass arguments,
you can do a bundle approach.
We also have a lot more things
around that specific case
that we'll be talking
about tomorrow as well,
as well as studying things
like separate animations
and other objects in here.
So you have a lot
of the same power,
but you can also make it
really easy to use and move
a lot of the code that
used to be a Fragment
transaction that you'd have to
make really sure that you got
right into something that
Navigation can understand
and help with.
So Adam, we've talked
to a lot of things
about why not Fragments.
But this is kind
of a Fragment talk.
ADAM POWELL: I think
that's why everyone's here.
IAN LAKE: Yeah.
So why Fragments?
It's 2018.
ADAM POWELL: It is 2018.
So what are fragments
still good for
after we've sort of carved off
some of these other extension
points?
So before we talk
about that, I think
it's kind of important
to go into a little bit
about the package layering
involved in the Android
framework, specifically
android.widget
versus android.app.
Now, android.widget is
really kind of designed
to hold all the
mechanism for your UI.
That means that this is all
the stuff that shows state
to the user and things that
reports user interaction
events back to other higher
level portions of your app.
And really that's it.
Anything that's in
the widget package
is really meant to only
do these two things.
Whereas android.app, which
is where Fragments live,
Activities live,
so on and so forth,
that's where your policy goes.
This is what defines what
state to bind to widgets.
This is what defines how you
should respond to those user
interaction events and
how to issue changes
to your data model.
Anything kind of at
that layer or above,
no matter how you
may factor it, this
is kind of how it breaks down.
So this also brings
us to this idea
of inflatable components,
which is something
that comes up quite a bit.
Since you can inflate a
Fragment from a layout,
people found out
really quickly that you
can use a Fragment to
compose some of your views
together and create
basically a custom view,
but with a Fragment.
And really some of
this kind of comes in
because people start asking,
just if this view had
a lifecycle, I could something.
But really, you kind of want
to use that as a stopping point
and just kind of
ask yourself, what
is it about this
particular view,
remember, mechanism only,
that needs a lifecycle?
Views should really
only be showing data
that they're given,
or publishing user
interaction events if
the user clicks, touches,
or performs any other action
on the views themselves.
None of these things
need lifecycle events
to accomplish that goal.
So you should really kind of
watch out and figure out, OK,
do you need some sort of policy
layer that sits above that?
This is where Fragments
are really useful,
because you can compose them
of higher level controls.
It means that they can
be self sufficient.
They have their own lifecycle.
They know how to hook
into some of these things.
It means that inflated
attributes can actually
become Fragment arguments.
So you can make these
things super self sufficient
and implement
crosscutting UI policies
that you don't have to
worry about in terms
of the overarching top
level parent context.
This ends up being really
useful for things like even just
something as simple as ads,
something where you really
do need to control for
a lifecycle about when
a user comes and goes,
perform a request out
to the network to fetch
the content that you're
going to show.
But really, you
don't want that code
getting all over throughout the
rest of your application logic.
You can use this for other
sorts of independent info
cards, things that are,
again, fully self-contained.
And the parent
doesn't actually need
to be involved in any
of the data routing
from your central repository
or whatever other sort of model
you're using under the hood
in order to get that on screen
and get the user
interacting with it.
So one example of using the
fragment arguments for this
is on screen here.
This is the sort of
thing that could probably
benefit from some
extensions or helpers.
But overall, it's not too bad.
If you define a
styleable to go ahead
and inflate some
of those arguments,
just assign the values to
the bundle, set it there,
and then you can route
all of this logic
through your normal
Fragment argument
handling that appears throughout
the rest of your Fragment
implementation.
IAN LAKE: So one of
the other use cases
that we found really
useful for using
Fragments is this kind of
app screen kind of model.
So where a Fragment is
taking the vast majority
of the screen, it's really
the main content of your app.
And this is really kind of where
Navigation comes in and really
kind of takes away a lot of
the rough edges of Fragments.
So you're just left with
the architecture component
hooks and a view.
So in this model,
it's a lot easier
to move towards a
single activity app.
If you listened
to Chet yesterday,
this is kind of
our recommendation
going forward, to
kind of use activities
just as an entry
point into your app.
And then your content,
the actual things
that the UI, the pieces that
developers or users actually
work with, are the
Fragments of your app.
The actual content
is in Fragments.
So with this model, the only
thing the Activity needs to do
is handle kind of
Common App Chrome.
So if you're using
an action bar still,
or if you're using
bottom nav or a side nav,
these would be good things
that the Activity can manage.
But the rest of it can be
decoupled destinations,
decoupled screens.
All of these Fragments can
be much more independent
from one another rather than
being tightly coupled together.
So this allows us to kind
of move a lot of the things
that normally you'd have to
deal with manually into a system
that we can help you
out a lot more on.
So for Navigation,
for example, we're
going to give you
the hooks that you
need to set up the transitions
and animations needed
to transition between
these screens.
And it's something that
can be done in Navigation
rather than something
you have to do by hand.
Of course, these aren't
mutually exclusive, right?
You can still add a
Fragment to your layout
or have nested Fragments
underneath these things.
So it's not an all or
nothing kind of an approach.
It's just one method that, yes,
this larger kind of content
based fragment is still
a really good way of kind
of bridging the gap
between the android.app
world and the widget world.
Another use case that
is still super useful
is around DialogFragment.
Again, we talked about
the activity show dialog.
I hope everyone forgot
that by now, like I said.
But DialogFragment is really
kind of the same approach
where instead of
it being something
that you need to manage and make
sure is visible or not visible,
it really kind of helps
encapsulate the interaction
between a floating UI.
Like, if you have a
really important question
to ask the user, a
dialog is probably
a useful case in some manner.
But it's also
something that we've
started to see a lot more.
In Android P, for instance,
the biometric prompt
for fingerprint is
now something that
is in a dialog kind of model.
So this is actually something
that we found really useful.
And part of it is
that we can leverage
some of that instant
state restoration
that you get for free as part
of Fragments with your dialog.
This means that you've asked
a really important question.
Otherwise, why would you show a
dialog and interrupt the user?
But you really don't want that
to disappear when you resize
your screen on the
Pixelbook or rotate
your device on your phone.
It's a really
important question.
We want to make sure that we
do some of this instant state
restoration for you.
At the same point, dialogs
aren't just a floating UI.
There's also bottom sheets and
bottom sheet DialogFragment
specifically built around
kind of having different kinds
of floating UIs.
UIs that live above
your main content,
without necessarily being just
the dimmed background kind
of traditional dialog of yore.
So we're really trying
to get to this point
where, yes, using
a DialogFragment
is great if you have
this UI that you really
don't want to lose.
It's really important
for the user.
Obviously, for things
that the user could lose,
it's probably not a dialog
that you want to use.
It's probably a snack bar
or another approach here.
This is my favorite part
about DialogFragment.
There's literally nothing
more you need to do.
You call show or show now
for the synchronous method,
and that's it.
Very much kind of
this model where
we're going to do the
Fragment transactions for you.
Again, we don't want
to be in a model
where you have to do a lot
of complicated work yourself.
For a DialogFragment, you
can literally just call show,
and it'll do the right
thing, and it'll get you back
into the right state.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So one of the other
things that people
tend to use Fragments
for quite a bit
is managing options menus, and
specifically merging some menus
into a common toolbar,
into an action bar
that's global to your Activity.
So Fragments
support option menus
because Activities
support options menus.
This kind of calls back to
that initial design goal,
where Fragments had to
be able to do anything
that an Activity could do.
And the most common
use case in this today
is for calling set
support action bar
for your toolbar, which
then sort of binds
whatever your current context
is to a particular toolbar
within your UI.
Now, this is really great if you
have some Fixed Common Chrome.
So in the navigation world,
if your toolbar never
changes between
screens, then this
is really handy
because this means
that you can populate
that with whatever actions
are relevant for what's
in your main content.
Fragment Pager Adapter is
another really great one
that people use this
for quite a bit.
If the actions change across
pages, then all of this
is just handled for you.
The system takes care of it.
Now, the alternative
to this is that you
can go ahead and directly manage
the menus as toolbar view data.
So most of the time
today, your UIs
are such that the toolbar or
other sort of menu management
is really kind of
part of the content.
I mean, this was something
that you saw back
in a lot of hollow UIs, where
the action bar was always
Fixed Common Chrome.
But now you have
these collapsing app
bar layouts and things that
are much more sophisticated,
to the point where doing
this sort of global wire
up is almost jumping through
hoops that you don't really
need.
So don't make it more
complicated than it
needs to be.
If you don't have
Common Chrome for this,
then directly managing some of
the toolbar menus as view data
is as simple as this.
It's a couple of lines of code.
There's not a whole lot to it.
You inflate your menu, you
attach a click listener.
And you can keep all of
this a little bit more
self-contained
rather than having
this leak out into the
whole Activity options menu
at that point.
So one of the other
things that we get
asked a lot is about
testing Fragments.
Testing Fragments is a whole lot
easier than testing Activities.
You don't have to
spin up the entirety
of the world and an entire new
Activity with sort of the back
and forth in an instrumentation
test to the Activity Manager
to make this work.
The nice part about this is
that from quite a few years ago,
we've had this class
Fragment Controller that
is able to drive the lifecycle.
So you can go ahead and
you can create just a test
Fragment Manager test
Fragment Controller that
can test those larger Fragment
components in isolation,
away from everything else
that might be happening
in the Activity Manager.
We use this pretty extensively
for the existing support
library tests ourselves.
Now, we make this possible,
but truth be told,
this is really not the best
interface for doing it.
It ends up looking a
little bit like this.
Or you could go through
some of the support
library tests in
AOSP and see kind
of the example of some
of the utility methods
that we've set up for this.
We should really probably
wrap this in some better move
to state type of method.
This is one of those
cases where we've
fallen into a trap ourselves
of something's possible.
It's maybe not great.
The rest is kind of left as
an exercise to the reader.
And we kind of just need
to do better on this part.
IAN LAKE: Yeah, so one
of the other pieces
that kind of came
alongside of Fragments,
more from a convenience
method than anything else,
were Loaders, a
kind of precursor
to a lot of what we've done
in architecture components
on doing retained
instance states.
And one of the things
we've done recently
is actually tried to
decouple them from Fragments.
So how do we actually do this?
Well, instead of being
their own special thing,
we actually rebuilt
them on a lot
of the architecture components.
Using these new primitives we
have a LiveData and ViewModel
to kind of make these a
totally independent thing.
So now you can actually use
Loaders in any lifecycle owner
ViewModel store owner class.
So Activity, Fragment,
if you're building
your own kind of thing.
It works equally well
in all of those cases.
So what does this mean?
Well, it really
just means that you
have the same Loader
you always do,
but instead of calling get
support Fragment or Loader
Manager, you can just
call get instance.
And we'll do all
the hookup for you.
We know that you're in
a lifecycle observer,
so we know how to hook
all that stuff up for you.
And we really were able to kind
of cut out a lot of the stuff,
cut a lot of the custom
behavior here so that we
can kind of rely
on these new things
to give you stronger
guarantees around lifecycle.
So we've talked a
lot about Fragments,
and we've talked a lot
about Fragments in the past,
and we've talked about
Fragments in 2018.
But there's another
question-- where are we
going with Fragments?
What do we still have to do?
So some of this is just
coming down to building
in those stronger guarantees.
Trying to separate
the desired behavior,
things that we
specifically set out
to put in, versus incidental
behavior, more behavior that
has just been
around for six years
and is not necessarily something
that is a codified standard.
So we're trying to move
towards more of a model
where you can be very
confident in exactly
what's going to happen when
you're using Fragments.
Another case is trying
to do the same thing
that we did with Loader
Manager in reimplementing
some of these existing APIs on
top of these new primitives.
For example, being
able to rewrite
a lot of the
internals of Fragments
so they're actually
using lifecycle observers
under the covers.
So these kinds of things
allow us to kind of make sure
that all of our components
are on the same page
and really doing the same thing.
So a few other things--
again, trying to
move towards a world
where we have the correct
set of signals and activity
callbacks so that any
interested components can be it.
That means that Fragments
are not a special snowflake
anymore.
They're just another component,
another tool in your toolbox,
using the same composable
hooks that you'd always have.
So really trying to play
well with other components
so that it's not an
either/or, it's a both.
That we can work
together, that you can use
fragments alongside other
components, and it just works.
ADAM POWELL: All right.
So Options menus are, of
course, one other thing
that we still don't have a great
answer for this in terms of how
we want to decouple this.
I mean, in a lot of ways I
would like for Options menus
just kind of as a
concept to be deprecated.
But for right now, we
still need to make sure
that we meet all those
same use cases for when
you do have Common Chrome
or for when you're paging
through some different content.
Next one maybe?
There we go.
OK, so
android.app.fragmentmanager,
some of you have noticed, is
now officially deprecated.
So no more of this kind
of behavior changing out
from under you having to design
against different variants
of it.
This works a whole lot
better in the Android X
packages and support
library before it,
because this means
that you no longer have
to worry about all the bugs
that were fixed over time.
It allows us to make larger
changes to the behavior in API.
Please send us your
wish list for the things
that you'd like to see us
do for some of this too.
We are going to be over in the
sandbox area right after this.
So please come say hello.
Tell us what you'd
like to see next.
And thank you very
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]